I was raised and all my friends were and
I know you were too that you don't ever
judge somebody for the color of their
skin it makes no sense scientifically
mathematically morally it's a ridiculous
way to live so we have made progress
with may progress no thanks to me but
thanks to a lot of people who put their
lives on the line and everything else
I don't think defunding the police is
the answer you see Minneapolis that's a
tricky right well but also it's it's
also a triggering word for people
because defunding doesn't mean you get
rid of the police never get rid of
please and there's been cities that have
defined a place that yes please in
murder one right the right wing wants
that yeah murder went through the roof
yeah yeah but remember when you see fun
hasta means taking money that you were
gonna give the police not getting really
police crime taking money from them put
in other stuff like education home like
there's other stuffs so let me let me
just it's a it's basically taking the
money from the police not getting rid of
the police but taking money from them
put an other avenue let me let me
context gonna help this is not defunding
the police has not new this this idea is
not a left-wing idea it's actually a lot
of right wing a lot of conservatives
libertarians actually believe in this
too not because they don't want a strong
police force because the police unions
are very very strong very good at
organizing and they get very good
benefits because they're very
politically active they're very
politically active in local politics or
more to the LAPD that's when you defund
by a hundred and fifty million dollars
what we're really talking about and this
has been floating around this is always
tried but it's politically precarious
but this is an opportunity you want to
take those programs put them in the Boys
and Girls Clubs you want to take those
programs and put them in crime drug
prevention programs there's a lot of
those programs are underfunded where the
police because they are very strong
Union organized those are that's
sometimes I'm sorry guys and I have a
lot of respect for the cops it's a
little over funded and you know it and
in fact when you look at pension plans
when you look at pension plans and you
can rely tired forty five with full
benefits and your whole family can a lot
of time
some towns don't have that tax base to
support that over and over and if you
disagree with me please see Stockton
California and I can give you a whole
list of a [ __ ] defund the police in
LA New York certain areas it's a bad
idea because if you think you have a
problem now with cops
if you defund these cops so that means
maybe now if you don't have those
incentives and they don't have those
401ks and those plans when they retire
you're not gonna get the smartest
brightest cops becoming cops you need
some bad apples Tommy now realize wrong
I don't think people realize number one
how hard that job is how well a lot of
cops do how how different it would be if
we didn't have such a professional
pull-offs when you say how hard is
that's the reason why they have those
retirement plans do you want to do what
they want to do there's our buddy joseph
azim loves to be a police officer it's
one of the best people I know and you
know my father-in-law retires in four
years even ax-cut for 30 years yeah and
and and he I'm sure he's a great cop and
but he also risked his life every day
sales to defund those guys you're going
down a weird road it's it's a very very
special markets like LA and New York yes
this is a really I don't like the words
defund the fun police or automatically
get to all of us kind of like wait a
minute what it sounds very erotic I'm
gonna go by gun yes what I would suggest
is defund the police means that the good
the cops are allocated a lot of money
politically on Minneapolis Minneapolis
time about defunding and and this take
way very did that now you got a City
Council full of very liberal very
probably not the smartest people on the
planet who are really you know yeah and
and what are you gonna do
you want to take so there's a reason
police forces are in place these people
know things have you too you know good
police forces and cops they study crime
like science and and and they use
technology and these police officers
they know [ __ ] it's just like anything
else they know [ __ ] that you would never
even think about yeah but but off you
back off as long as you're following off
30 years he knows [ __ ] that you and I
have know there are nuances and details
if you want to rethink it you want a
city council to rethink the thing about
who said a lot of a lot of celebrities
like you know John Legend and his wife
for like let's defund the police let's
do this but I don't give a [ __ ] about
that wound up a hold on blunt
so they're saying this let's different
they're not gonna be affected by it at
all because they're hiring private
security and off-duty police officers
that protect them no [ __ ]
so just a fun place so they can't help
out I don't give a [ __ ] about Hollywood
celebrities and and if they're talking
including probably me and I'm not a
Hollywood celebrity if Hollywood
celebrities like John Legend and Christy
Teegan are talking I don't give a [ __ ]
yeah there's well almost shouldn't count
there it doesn't count well because
they're in Beverly Hills and then
they're saying 'die fun place but it's
not gonna it's I can affect their lives
at all cuz they're high in private
security which most the time are
off-duty police office if you're a
[ __ ] politician and you got an and
everybody starts Beyonce and jay-z and
John Legend and [ __ ] Robert Downey
jr. whoever it might be comes out in
support of you it might be the worst
thing for you because Americans
immediately go those people don't live
my lifestyle
hey you're you're though you're a couch
with a bunch of Hollywood celebrities
sipping five five thousand-dollar bottle
might get the [ __ ] out here you don't
know my problems [ __ ] and
usually it works against John so I can
have to deal with it huh they're not
gonna be last and Hollywood yeah I can't
stand how fickle it is it was
transgender it was me - it was kovat and
now it's and now it's [ __ ] uh racism
these people are like you never see a
cat chasing a light beam yeah here's he
had triplets a nut powder is that color
the way they're like that man like that
so I don't give a [ __ ] about these
fickle people I don't give a [ __ ] cuz
they'd go with whatever's popular they
don't have any they don't really know
how bad yeah no [ __ ] I have a back get
the [ __ ] out it I don't get hey make me
[ __ ] laugh sing songs dance do what
the [ __ ] you know that that's what we do
did the don't start getting to your
you're too self-involved shut up and
dribble no I know you have your right
you have your right you have your right
to say whatever you want but I wish
Christy Teegan and [ __ ] John Legend
had given instead of giving money to
bailout protesters I wish they had given
money that $200,000 to a small
minority-owned business to bail them out
never to a poor family something who
really needs it but that's their right
that's their right it's my right to
criticize them it's their right to do it
right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue okay what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]